بعد نحو 50 سنه من الغموض الذي لف قصتها
وتحقيقات عده فشلت في فكه كندا تحل اخيرا
لغز قضيه سيده صحيفه الجارديان البريطانيه
كشفت ان السلطات الكنديه عثرت على جثه
سيده في نهر نيشان الواقعه غربي مدينه
مونتريال في الثالث من مايو عام
1975 السلطات لم تستطع التوصل لهويه
السيده انذاك وبعد نحو 50 سنه من
التحقيقات تم التوصل الاجابات عبر تقنيه
علم الانساب الجيني الجنائي شرطه انطار
الكنديه كشفت ان الجثه تعود لامراه تدعى
وهي سيده اعمال من ولايه تنس الامريكيه
كما توصلت الى المتهم بقتلها وهو روندي
نيكولاس امريكي الجنسيه كان يعيش في ولايه
فلوريدا وقدمت كندا لامريكا طلبا لتسلمه
الشرطه رجحت ان الضحيه السافرت مع القاتل
الى مونتريال في ابريل عام
1975 ومن يومها انقطع خبرها عن اهلها
ليعصر عليها جثه ه امده فيما لم يتم الكشف
عن دافع القتل حتى الان